Let's go to our caller from the eight three
two area code who's calling today from eight
three to.
I David, it's me.
Yes, it is.
All right.
Thanks for picking up my call, and I know
you're not a historian, David, but this election
to you, you know, do you think it's just an
unprecedented election or do you see any similarities
between this election?
You know, any previous election you've lived
in war in history.
So in terms of similarities, I'm less clear,
what I can tell you is it's the most important
election I will be voting in.
And earlier in the week, I gave this example
of, you know, in 2012 when Barack Obama had
been in for four years, we were in the middle
of an economic recovery.
Mitt Romney was was running against Barack
Obama and he didn't really have a great case
as to why you should even really vote for
him.
And he's going to lower taxes for rich people.
And he had some, you know, different different
ideas about the direction he wanted to take
health care.
And, of course, socially, Romney was much
more conservative.
But I said leading up to that election, I
believe Barack Obama is the better candidate
and I believe Barack Obama has earned a second
term.
But it was not the most important election
in that most likely the economy was going
to probably do well between 2012, 2013 and
2017, regardless of whether it was Romney
or Obama.
This is a very different situation where our
ability to recover from four years of Trump
is dramatically more plausible than recovering
from eight years of Donald Trump.
And so in terms of its unprecedented nature,
this is without a doubt the most important
election I will be voting in.
Interesting, interesting, and I'm guessing
that in 2016, not at the time, that was the
most important election year voting, but this
has superseded.
What's crazy is there was a large.
Well, let me let me back up.
There was a group of people on the left who
in 2016 was saying this doesn't feel that
important.
I mean, you know, corporate, corporate, corrupt
Hillary versus Trump.
I don't care if it's not going to be Bernie.
It doesn't make it.
Look at how consequential the 2016 election
was.
Consider how different things would be on
the virus today if it had been Hillary Clinton
rather than Donald Trump.
And so I believe that there were a lot of
people who didn't think 2016 was that important.
In retrospect, we know that that was very,
very wrong.
Interesting, yeah, no, I agree with that,
I definitely agree.
Yeah.
With with Hillary, I think the approach to
the virus would have been probably an absolute
office and it would have been not about Hillary,
it would have been about doctors, whereas
now it's all about Trump and Trump's fights
with doctors and etc.
If it had been Hillary, it would have been
much less about fireworks.
It would have been we're having doctors run
this.
We're having doctors make decisions because
that's who should be doing it.
Public health officials.
Yeah.
Yeah, she would have been a good administrator
in the sense of delegating.
Yes or no?
Yeah.
Thanks for taking my call.
Appreciate it.
Thank you so much for the call.
We're going to take a brief break.
But if you're holding, don't hang up.
That's my advice, because I'm going to go
right back to the phones after this short
break.